[Music]
some people call me the space cowboy
some call me the gangster of love
some people got me Maurice
cause I speak of the pompadus of love
you're the cutest thing that I ever did
ever did really love your beaches I
wanna shake your tree
lovely lovely lovely dummy love me don't
be all the time
oh we baby I should show you a good time
cause I'm a picker I'm a grinner I'm a
lover I'm a sinner
I blame our music in the Sun
and I'm a joker I'm a smoker I'm a
midnight talker
[Music]
in the sun yeah and I'm a joker I'm a
smoker I'm a midnight talker
I get my love
yeah
whoa
people talk about me baby
say I'm doing you wrong
don't you worry no dollar no don't worry
cause I'm right here writer writer write
it on
and you're the cutest thing that I ever
did see
I really love your beaches I wanna shake
your tree
all the time
[Music]
cause I'm a picker I'm a grinner I'm a
lover and I'm a sinner
foreign
[Music]
ER I'm a lover and I'm a sinner
I play my music in the Sun
and I'm a joker I'm a smoker I'm a
midnight talker
I get my loving on the Run yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
thank you